What we wear says a lot about who we are.
Yet fashion is also a
$2.5 trillion industry
that touches everyone on Earth.
I'm Imran Amed.
I first started trying to make
sense of the fashion business
15 years ago, as it was being
transformed by technology,
globalization, and
shifting consumer values.
And so stuff like this would
just end up in a landfill.
Yeah.
Now I'm on a journey to see
how fashion is recalibrating
after the pandemic to
balance profit with purpose.
This is the Business of Fashion Show.
Join me to discover how fashion
shapes, business, culture,
and identity,
and to meet the people
forging fashion's future.
Well, I'm back here in Paris
for the first time in 16 months.
And it's the first time the
global fashion community
is really getting
together since March 2020.
It's Haute Couture Week,
the most exclusive,
most elaborate and most creative event
on the fashion calendar.
This is a world of rules and traditions,
of exquisite workmanship
and high net worth clients
able to pay six figures for a gown.
Do you buy couture?
Absolutely.
Yeah.
Yet the trailblazing
designers we're about to meet
may not be what you expect.
Among them, a true disruptor in fashion,
the man who made a billion dollar industry
out of ugly sneakers
is staging Balenciaga's first couture show
in over 50 years.
How are you?
We had an exclusive preview.
Couture, for me, has something very modern
in its concept because we only
produce what somebody orders.
This is like the most
sustainable way of consuming.
And the rising star of Paris,
whose highly creative
collections placed the planet
before profit, embedding sustainability
into her design process.
We really have to think about the planet
that we are destroying every day,
so I was hoping that maybe, you know,
some other people of the fashion industry
were thinking about that.
But to really understand what's happening
in Paris this week,
it's important to take
stock of the last 18 months.
2020 was the worst year in
the history of modern luxury.
Before that, annual revenues
for the luxury fashion market
topped $380 billion.
More than two thirds of growth was buoyed
by the Chinese, at home, but
especially as tourists abroad.
The lion's share of revenues
came from accessories,
especially handbags, with
designer sneakers catching up.
Then, Wuhan, China locked down.
Covid hit Europe during the
2020 spring fashion show season.
Giorgio Armani livestreamed his show
from an empty theater in Milan,
but other brands forged on,
with shows packed full
of fashion insiders.
In a global business so interconnected,
unforeseen consequences of
the pandemic came to light.
Delayed weddings led to
canceled embroidery orders
out of Paris,
threatening the livelihoods
of the Karigar artisans of India.
Luxury revenues plunged by more than 20%.
Companies cut costs.
But by the end of 2020,
Covid-19 had still devastated
industry profitability.
Fashion was forced to adapt,
using technology to drive
creative and business innovation.
The fashion business was re-imagined
through distance selling, online
films and virtual fashion.
The luxury industry bounced back,
dominated by the mega
brands, Hermes and Chanel,
and the mega groups, LVMH,
Kering and Richemont.
By the first half of 2021
revenues for some of the biggest names
were up as much as 40%
on pre-pandemic levels
delivering record profits.
From an economic perspective,
these super winners are
emerging from the pandemic
even stronger.
Now, there is a reawakening in Paris,
the global capital of luxury fashion.
It's a historical echo.
The last time fashion
burst back to life here
was after World War Two,
with the sensation that was
Christian Dior's "New Look".
It will take more than a new silhouette
to transform the fashion industry now.
I mean, the big question
for me is, really,
where does the industry go from here?
And you know, how does it
need to adapt and change
to be kind of fit for this new world
that we're entering?
To find out more about this reawakening,
I met with a fashion insider
with his finger on the creative
pulse of Parisian fashion.
Pierre!
Hey Imran, how are you?
Good, how are you?
I'm good.
Pierre Alexandre M'Pelé,
also known as Pam Boy,
caught the ear of fashion insiders
for his honest online fashion critiques.
Is that an earring?
Yeah, it's Alan Crocetti,
it's like a little rose.
I was like, fashion moment.
Now, he collaborates with
the respected fashion editor,
Katie Grand, at Perfect,
a fashion media company
founded amid the pandemic.
What is La Perle, like, why
did you pick this place?
Who comes here?
Everyone, it's you know,
designers and, you know,
we always joke about, you know,
dress well and come to La Perle
and you'll get an internship
or you'll find a job.
In the 1960s or '70s,
there was no luxury industry, you know?
But now luxury is this global industry,
and what's the role of luxury?
I mean, I think the role of luxury
is to preserve craftsmanship.
We tend to, you know, look
down on manual work and craft,
and I think luxury,
if anything, has always been about that.
Going back to Louis XIV in France
and how he developed, you know,
the French fashion industry
as we know it today.
As you think about the fashion industry
we want to create for the future,
do you feel like there's
actually real change happening
or is it at the surface?
I mean, I feel like changing
the structures of power
in the industry and how they interconnect,
I feel like companies need to take risks.
They need diversity and inclusion.
I feel like fashion is
a global conversation.
Everyone is concerned, you know.
I don't think that would have happened
if it weren't for the pandemic.
I mean, Paris felt weird, you know,
between the pandemic and
the whole conversation
of Black Lives Matter,
which was something very new in France,
I feel like as soon as we started talking
about systemic racism in the industry,
a lot of people reached out
to me and came to realize that
fashion is also about how
do we want society to be,
for example, in the '60s
with the sexual revolution,
and women started wearing miniskirt,
that was fashion changing
society and shaping society,
and you know, pushing
new ideas about womanhood
and what a woman could be,
and now with menswear,
there's been a lot of
conversation about masculinity,
what it means to be a man,
and I think that it's questions
that fashion can answer
fashion is probably the best, you know,
medium to answer those questions.
I always say, it's time
to open the windows.
We need a fresh breeze of
newness to kind of, you know,
swipe through to the industry.
It really does feel like
change is the watchword here.
As I caught up with top
designers and creatives
in town for Paris Fashion Week.
You know, everyone was
talking about a reset,
are we going back to where we were?
I hope not personally, but I
mean, change is a subtle one.
I mean, the truth of the matter is,
we've got centuries and
decades of this fashion world
and fashion business and
hopefully the mentalities evolve.
And I don't think we
should go back completely
to where we were.
There is like, it's a big movement
going into that opening
of different gender
and also races, all that opening.
The majority are for the opening,
and the minority is the
ones that are against it.
That is a big change.
I think that the clientele
in the past two years,
it's gone from being a very
Western clientele actually,
and one really rooted and
based in the United States,
to being much more global.
Creativity needs to be
balanced with business.
The most crucial decision
any fashion CEO makes
is the selection of a creative director
who can inform the entire
universe of the brand,
not just the collections and the clothes,
but also the stores, the advertising,
and in the digital age,
the social media strategy.
The legendary designer Karl Lagerfeld
was creative director at Fendi
for more than half a century
and had a lifelong contract with Chanel,
where he worked until he died in 2019.
But more recently, designers
have been switching sides
at a fast clip,
akin to soccer managers in transfer season
netting the right striker.
Although in this game,
when talents transfer
between historic houses,
it's known to insiders as musical chairs.
When Balenciaga's parent company Kering
acquired the brand in 2001,
it was doing only $17.3
million in revenue.
That has all changed.
Analysts say it's doing almost
2 billion Euros in sales,
which makes it one of the biggest,
most important fashion
houses in the world.
A large part of this success
is down to its creative
director, Demna Gvasalia,
who has injected his dystopian
vision into the brand,
with experience honed at the
Antwerp Academy of Fine Arts,
Maison Martin Margiela, and Louis Vuitton.
From Georgian refugee to
master fashion disruptor,
Demna is part of a group of designers
including Virgil Abloh and Kim Jones
who brought the streetwear phenomenon
to the highest levels of European fashion.
He's the creative mind
behind Balenciaga's first couture show
in more than 50 years.
This is the 50th couture collection,
because Mr. Balenciaga
himself did 49 collections.
So this is the 50th collection,
it's Demna's first couture collection.
And so it's probably the most important,
most anticipated moment
of this Couture Week,
and we're getting the first look at it.
It's like the gate to couture.
That's correct.
So, they're about to start the fittings.
They have to allocate which
model is gonna wear which look.
But now the fittings
have also become a moment
to capture content to share later.
So there's a whole
photograph setup as well.
And you can just tell
by the energy in here,
there's lots of anticipation
because some of the looks
are being revealed for the first time.
Nobody in the whole world
outside this building
has seen this collection.
An emigre himself,
Cristobal Balenciaga
shaped the fashion scene
through the 1940s and '50s,
with his sculptural masterpieces,
until he shuttered the house in 1968.
How are you feeling?
Good, very excited,
now it's the moment
actually, the hardest one,
where I cannot change anything anymore.
I can just shorten the lengths-
So you're not one of the ones
who changes things the night before?
No, but in couture also, you can't.
Okay.
Our interview takes place
in the recently restored
Balenciaga couture salon,
where tomorrow, in a show
with just 128 attendees,
including Kanye West, Lewis Hamilton
and Kering chairman and
CEO Francois-Henri Pinault,
Demna will pay homage
to the brand's history,
underscoring, the intimacy
and rarity of haute couture.
So I wanted to start with
where we are right now.
Can you tell me what this place signifies
to the house of Balenciaga?
This actual space salon,
where we're sitting,
is where the couture clients would come
during the Cristobal Balenciaga era.
Originally it was the salon.
It was the salon,
this is the place where the
founder of this house would come
and create his legacy that
we're living through today.
It's symbolic, I don't know,
it's symbolic for my showing
respect to the legacy
that I'm lucky enough
to be in the middle of.
And now the couture has been in making
for over one year almost.
And it's the first live event
that we're going to have,
even if the audience is going to be
quite restricted and small.
What is your vision
for Balenciaga couture?
I would say rather than my vision,
my mission in couture is to
actually give it a second life.
I heard people saying couture
is dead, who needs it?
You know, it's completely useless.
But I'm afraid of what's
going to be in 20, 30 years.
After bursting onto the fashion scene
with the brand collective Vetements,
Demna took the helm of Balenciaga in 2015
as part of a radical modernization,
including the Triple S,
which set afire the ugly sneaker trend
and helped Balenciaga surpass
a billion dollars in revenue in 2019,
spawning a thousand copycats.
His fashion shows have been
as disruptive as his designs,
set in an enormous television studio
on the outskirts of the
Peripherique in Paris.
He's cast runway models
outside the traditional mold.
I like the fact that there's
boys at a couture show,
that's on your show, right?
And the Balenciaga couture show
this week will feature men,
women, and non-binary people,
something that has not been
part of traditional couture
Karl Lagerfeld occasionally
featured men's couture
on his Chanel runways,
but it was not made available for sale.
I feel like talking about gender
is like talking about the
day before yesterday's news,
you know, we shouldn't
even be talking about it.
We should just be living it, in fashion.
And for me, the fact that
you saw boys and girls
and non-binary people in my cast.
Giving couture to men, for example,
for me they had to pay back some.
And so I wanted them to wear heels,
and to feel how it is to wear heels
and to see what it does
to different type of guys.
Does some of this motivation,
to bring this into kind of
mainstream fashion and culture,
come from having grown up in Georgia
during the time of the Soviet Union?
That wasn't a place where conversations
around gender identity, homosexuality-
So, I think there is a direct
link, for me personally,
with the culture in which I
grew and don't ask, don't tell,
I mean, officially there
are no gays in Georgia,
you know, so obviously
it was a taboo subject.
I mean, I've been more
terrorized by homophobia
than the actual civil war,
so I feel like it is in me,
it's something that I have to do.
It's almost like a therapy
in a way to do that.
And since fashion is
the mirror of our times,
I think it is kind of
part of my job, almost.
Yeah.
What's your take on what we should learn
from the last 16 months of pause?
You know, I like to raise
questions through my work,
you know, sustainability,
like raising questions
about consumption in general.
I mean, it's kind of ironic,
because I'm in the middle of the system
that encourages the consumption.
But what I'm trying to do,
bringing couture to it,
is actually start a conversation
about thinking twice about consumption.
I think, you know, couture for me
has something very modern in its concept
because we only produce
what somebody orders.
So this is like the most
sustainable way of consuming,
but obviously the industry
cannot live on that.
But I think it is also about
finding that balance, you know,
this pandemic made me, before pandemic,
I never thought about it.
I was like a hamster in a
wheel just making stuff,
and making it and making it.
But the irony is, you need
to sell mountains of sneakers
in order to be able to sustain
both this couture collection
and the business, right?
You called it balance.
I think it is balance,
I think it's balance,
and it's also understanding
what people want from fashion.
I think that's the good starting point,
because they don't want all of that stuff
that is being produced.
They don't need it, they don't want it.
And to be honest, they
don't care about it.
Fashion has become too busy
to notice that, you know.
The industry, and I feel that
pandemic gave that, somehow,
possibility to take a step
back and to kind of look at it
from objectively and to understand
you don't need all of that.
Recognizing the impact
fashion has on the planet
is a step forward.
But the scale of the problem is vast,
and the necessary change
can feel intimidating.
Some designers prefer to work
outside of the big houses,
turning down lucrative offers
instead to focus on their own brands.
One such designer is the
rising star of Paris fashion,
whose studio in the 19th arrondissement
is bursting with old garments
that she repurposes to create
her highly acclaimed collections.
Wow.
I met with Marine Serre to get her take
on how the pandemic is changing fashion
and to learn if that change
is happening fast enough.
So this is our upcycle room,
where we are making garment
from regenerated fabric.
We take these from
warehouses, it's all waste,
and already used garment.
But do they just sell it in bulk?
Yeah, so they have like tons
and tons and tons of garment,
when you enter into this place,
you realize also how fashion industry
have been like producing
so much the last 50 years.
So basically, this is our past, I mean,
this is the past of
fashion and we are like,
taking piece of it and selecting into that
to make new garments.
And then no garment is
the same either, right?
Because every piece is different.
All of them, they are unique.
And the only thing that repeats
is the process of making.
But indeed the piece itself,
like if this will be on
the back of your shirt,
all of the shirt would be different.
Right.
It was Marine's grandfather,
a collector and secondhand dealer,
who first taught her the value of vintage.
Looking at fashion through an
ethical and sustainable lens
allowed Marine to foresee
many of the issues
that the industry is only
just starting to wake up to.
You know, and you clearly feel very deeply
about the state of the world.
You think deeply about the
climate and the environment,
but you're now saying you feel optimistic.
Well, I think before it was more about
ringing the bell, alarming people,
because like in the fashion industry,
no one was looking at that
and I was also working
for this industry,
so I do not want it to be
a part of just being there
and making one more skirt,
you know, I was hoping
that maybe, you know,
some other people of the fashion industry
were thinking about that too.
We really have to think about, yeah,
the environment that we are living in
and the planet that we
are destroying every day.
So if I'm there, I have to,
at least making a small change.
So what is luxury to you and
what is that luxury customer
that you are appealing to,
what are they looking for?
I believe that you can
feel it when you touch it.
I think people that are in
fashion for long, they will know,
you know how this thing is stitch.
And even if you don't
know like this old thing,
you will feel it, like for me,
it's really joyful when
I take a cushion cover
and then I can transform it
into a shirt that look cool.
I'm like, yeah, that's nice.
What is the goal of the company?
I think the goal of the company
is to question the fashion industry,
try to resolve some of the question.
I mean, basically every
day we are doing that
and it's to make an ecosystem,
a new ecosystem kind of exist.
A fashion business does not
succeed on aesthetics alone.
Now more than ever,
those designs need to be
rooted in clear values.
Sustainability, for me,
it has become a very
personal thing, really,
just maybe doing couture is my way
taking a minute of silence,
almost, to reflect.
This is why the show will
be in a full silence.
No music?
There will be no music,
this is the first time,
I never showed my work in silence.
Wow.
That minute of silence, it's very symbolic
from what I just told you
about fashion as an industry,
all the white noise,
things that don't matter.
I've seen designers injecting
more of their personal
values into their designs
and asking provocative
questions about fashion
and its role in the world.
Marine and Demna are asking how fashion
can more positively impact
the people in our communities,
the societies we live in,
and the planet we all share.